Good morning.
I'm delighted to introduce our
next speaker, Keith Block.
He's a great friend of mine personally,
but
also a great friend of the university and
of the Heinz College.
Keith is a distinguished
alumnus of the Heinz College,
a member of my Dean's Advisory Council,
and a member of the Board of Trustees.
He's also called CEO of Salesforce and
member of the Board of Directors.
Keith serves and
has served a number of important roles.
He's the company's Vice Chairman,
President and served
as a Director since joining the company
in June 2013, and additionally,
served as the company's chief
operating officer since February 2016 -
clearly, a multidimensional,
multi-talented person.
As president and COO of Salesforce, Keith
oversaw the company's multi-billion dollar
global sales and services business,
alliances and channels, industry strategy,
corporate development, corporate affairs,
marketing and business operations.
In February 2018, Keith and
his wife Suzanne established
the Block Center for
Technology and Society at CMU.
This important center, which is
cross-cutting and university-wide will
foster critical dialogue on campus to
create inclusive and meaningful plans
of action on topics such as the future of
work and issues of trust and transparency
in the use of autonomous systems to
improve the quality of life for all.
Keith holds a Master of Science
Degree in Management and
Policy Analysis from the Heinz College and
a Bachelor's Degree in Information
Systems from Dietrich College.
So he was ahead even then at being at
this nexus of technology in society.
In addition to his membership on
the Carnegie Mellon University Board of
Trustees, he's also currently a member of
the World Economic Forum's Information
Technology community as a governor and
on the advisory board of
our Heinz College and the board
of trustees of the Concord Museum.
Please join me in welcoming
Keith Block to the podium, Keith.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Well, thank you, Krishnan.
You've made me blush this morning,
so I appreciate that.
And thank you very much for
that very kind introduction.
So first I wanna say,
good morning, everybody.
>> Good morning.
>> Okay, that was my best Farnam.
>> [LAUGH]
>> I gave it a run, my friend.
Anyway, good morning to everybody.
Faculty, alumni, staff,
family and friends,
it is an honor to be here today to
celebrate the investiture of a great man,
Dr. Farnam Jahanian, as president
of Carnegie Mellon University.
In all of life's endeavors, Farnam
has led with a tremendous spirit and
an unrivaled dedication.
Whether as a world renowned
computer scientist,
a passionate, successful entrepreneur,
a tireless public servant or
a world class leader in higher education.
And by the way, just an incredible,
incredible human being.
Now I've had the opportunity to
work very closely with Farnam.
And we have shared many
experiences around career and
our life journeys, including
everybody's favorite, parenthood.
And Farnam, by the way, that advice you
gave me about curfews for teenage kids,
thank you so much for that.
I would never have thought of that myself.
>> [LAUGH]
>> [COUGH] But thank goodness it worked.
Over the years, we've had a very, very
close relationship and friendship, and for
that, I'm very, very grateful.
Professionally, I've also had
the opportunity to observe Farnam
in his influence and guiding policy
at the world economic forum
and I will tell all of you,
he has represented this
university incredibly well.
I've also witnessed his leadership here
at CMU personally with students and
faculty and staff and
members of the Board of Trustees.
And whether it's uniting the community to
support the Special Olympics,
where I understand he has a passion for
dunk tanks -
do you just wanna come up and
tell everybody about this dunk tank?
alright,
I'm sure you'll get to that at some point -
or really fostering engagement between
students from different colleges,
Farnam has a talent, a true talent for
bringing people together and
breaking down walls.
Farnam is also a leader with impeccable
integrity and the highest of character.
He conducts himself with grace, and
dignity, and thoughtfulness and warmth.
There is no question, no question,
Farnam will guide this institution into
the future and
accelerate its impact on the world.
So today,
we witness the passing of the torch
to an incredibly talented individual.
Now this torch has been held by many,
many great leaders throughout
Carnegie Mellon's very rich history
and there have been so
many accomplishments and so
many historic milestones.
Since Andrew Carnegie founded
a technical school in 1900,
individuals of great character and
honor have taken the reigns of leadership
of this very prestigious institution.
And each of them have led with courage and
vision, names like Hamerschlag,
Doherty, Stever, Cyert, Cohon.
Those are but a few.
Each of these presidents and
others of the storied institution
led through myriad of chapters of
American history, world history.
The turn of the century,
the Great Depression,
the explosion of technology that Jim was
talking about just a few minutes ago,
civil unrest, war and peace
and throughout all of this, the presidents
of Carnegie Mellon have guided
this institution to the forefront
of educational excellence
and they have shaped the minds of so
many young people
all the while ensuring that the university
remained a source of inspiration,
a guiding light, a beacon of hope.
And now we pass this
torch to Farnam Jahanian.
There was no one who is better suited
to lead us into the next chapter
and this next chapter is
arguably the most important ever.
For we do live in very,
very interesting times.
We have seen, and
this is just the beginning, but
we have seen incredible
advances in technology.
We are at the dawn of a new era.
Some refer to it as the fourth
industrial revolution.
And this is where we have the convergence,
the perfect storm of social and mobile and
deep learning and artificial
intelligence and 3D printing and
amazing technologies, all brought
together to drive incredible innovation.
Now like many of you,
I had the opportunity and
good fortune to speak with other CEOs and
world leaders
and what is top of mind
in that group is how to
harness this wave of innovation
in a very positive way.
This convergence of technology is
having a profound impact on our world.
We see it in our daily lives.
It has also brought great disruption and
given rise to many, many questions.
What will these new technologies be?
Will they be positive for mankind?
What are the socioeconomic effects?
What are the privacy implications?
What will be the regulatory issues?
What will be the future of work?
And Farnam is passionate about these
questions and even more passionate
about CMU leading the way to drive
those answers to these questions.
These are all important issues of our time
that we have to consider in a thoughtful
and meaningful and measured way.
We are clearly at an inflection point.
These advances must be for good.
They must enlighten.
They must empower.
And they must take humanity
to greater heights.
And in a world where there is
an ever increasing divide,
these advances must create opportunity for
all, not just a few.
So that all of mankind can participate and
contribute.
Now this will take vigilance, it will take
dedication, and it will take leadership.
And this is why the faculty, the staff,
the students, this community at
Carnegie Mellon are so critical to
the future of this nation, this society,
this world, for the young minds that we
shape here have an important mission.
They will go forth into the world
with the knowledge, the vision, and
the ethics that Carnegie Mellon
has instilled in them.
And they will go forward into
the world to solve universal
issues that lie at the intersection
of technology and humanity.
The graduates of CMU must
be equipped to thrive and
lead in a world in uncertainty for
these are truly uncertain times.
Today the value of trust is
being questioned more than ever.
Trust in technology, trust in our
institutions, trust in our leaders.
Some would say there is a crisis of trust.
And this crisis of trust has
created a leadership void.
And now individuals, and
companies, and faculty, and
students alike must fill this breach.
And it will be the graduates of CMU that
will answer this call for leadership.
And for them, it is a call to arms.
It is a call to arms for us all.
It is an obligation to lead in
an ethical and transparent way,
to engage in constructive civil discourse,
where disagreements will arise,
and that's okay, but
dialogue must happen with respect.
And while there can be differing opinions,
there cannot be differing facts.
And most important, most important,
to restore trust in our society,
because without trust, we have nothing.
It will be the graduates of Carnegie
Mellon that will be called upon to
cultivate and drive a culture of
success in business and society.
Where the core tenants of diversity,
empathy, equality, humanity,
accountability and opportunity for
all are at the forefront.
Never before has this institution
been more important to the world.
Never before has leadership at the
intersection of technology and society and
humanity been as critical
as it is right now.
And though the future is unwritten,
I am very confident, very confident that
the graduates of CMU will be the authors
of a great future for all of us.
Now as we stand at the doorstep
of this new world,
the dawn of a new era, we need a truly
special leader to help guide and
shape the lives of those who will
determine the future, all of our futures.
And never before has the presidency
of this institution been
as important as it is right now.
And it requires a remarkable leader,
a truly outstanding human being.
And that person is Dr. Farnam Jahanian.
We stand with Farnam today as
he takes his rightful place
amongst the great presidents
of Carnegie Mellon.
I cannot imagine a better leader
who embodies the values of CMU.
I cannot imagine a better
leader with as much vision,
with as much passion, with as much focus
and I cannot imagine a better leader and
torch bearer of this great institution.
Farnam, we are very lucky to have you.
You are the right leader,
as Jim says, at the right time.
So ladies and gentlemen, please join me
in congratulating a true friend, a great
leader, and the next president of Carnegie
Mellon University, Dr. Farnam Jahanian.
>> [APPLAUSE]